l'histoire de Doctor Strange est une grande distribution
de personnages dont le principal est Carla
Mordo et bien c'est certainement l'intro de
dr.  étrange entrant dans cet univers, Mauro
est très proche de l'ancien
joué par Tilda Swinton, elle s'occupe de la
magie dans une véritable magie intérieure
, à la fois l'ancien et Mauro,
ils commencent en quelque sorte sa formation, il
existe d'autres moyens de sauver des vies.
Je ne sais pas que
nous sommes enthousiasmés par les méchants dans ce
film pour les appeler les fanatiques, ce sont des
gens qui sont séduits par ce qu'ils
trouvent de l'autre côté considèrent qu'ils font partie
de ce temple si la majorité
cherche la vérité ici, il
cherche là-bas  la vérité, il est
intéressé à renverser les barrières
entre ces dimensions
dr.  étrange tu penses que tu sais comment le
monde fonctionne et si je te disais que la
réalité tu sais est l'une des nombreuses
cela n'a aucun sens
tout n'a
pas de sens
pour les arts mystiques nous exploitons l'énergie
et façonnons la réalité
nous parcourons de grandes distances  en un instant
si je vais d'ici à là comment es-tu
devenu médecin étudiant la pratique
hier
il y a une force pour lui où ils voient
prêts
quels chemins tu parcoures des
hommes étranges plus forts que tu es décédés
je suis la mort
quand
tu mourras  pour affronter ce monde
je ne peux pas faire ça il n'y a pas d'autre moyen